if you've been here in New York it has
been dominated by the UN General
Assembly the annual event where
delegates come from all over the world
to up this city's traffic almost
every world leader has been here but no
one has had a bigger impact than Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi just this
morning he gave a sold-out speech at
Madison Square Garden that featured
everything from dance numbers to a live
on stage painter creating a speed
portrait of him I've gotta say Modi
classic out-of-towner move comes to New
York stays a few days and leaves with a
slapdash caricature done in the Time
Square area you're a cliche Modi you're
a cliche but perhaps Modi's crowning
glory during the trip was his appearance
at last night's global citizen concert
in Central Park it wasn't that he gave a
great speech it's that he had one hell
of a finish thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
paintin particular to loot jackman god
bless you may the pose be pure wow that
is a power move right there standing
next to Wolverine and throwing out star
wars quotes bear in mind this guy was
banned from entering the United States
up until just four months ago for his
role in the good you're at riots that's
quite a turnaround for him and let me
say this to all other world leaders this
is the new bar do not turn up to this
city again unless you are with an a-list
movie star and throwing out quotes from
films that they were definitely not in
for instance Robert Mugabe is not
welcome here unless he's standing next
to Billy Crystal shouting to infinity
and beyond but no reason whatsoever and
I do not want to see Angela Merkel set
foot on American soil unless she is with
Vin Diesel and screaming I will have
what she's having
[Applause]